sei que esta época lessa
tudo aquilo que eu quero mostrar é que
determinados paulo que cria a aliança
selada nos a nós queremos explicar o que
estava a estudar pátria
este número quer fazer história que é o
número que nos diz o que 30% do que nós
somos ex médico
se você tiver algum defeito devem o
genus devem-nos os seus pais 70% e
apreendido
ora este valor que eu quero na verdade
nos centremos 70%
por isso quando nós falamos em gestão do
estresse e da ansiedade criar situações
novas
o autor que eu gosto muito estimado por
ele próprio em plenas tem nome fármaco é
um senhor que médico formação russo e
diz que nós somos o que somos reflex dos
ambientes dos quais nos comportamos ao
longo da nossa vida
ou seja diz quem é com quem andas e eu
digo que é quem tem doença
por isso nós temos que na verdade
perceber muitas vezes quando na
realidade encontramos ao que é novo que
nos cria ansiedade pois a ansiedade
todos nós que vamos ter
temos é que ter a cidade que nos permita
verdadeiramente sobreviver
olha a cidade todos nós sabemos se
quando andamos quando entramos para
coisas novas não é acaba sempre criar
algo que verdadeiramente impactantes na
vida da pessoa seja eu tenho que vir
para a faculdade teve pode ter que
estudar possa já vim down vaia que
estava habituado à minha família e aos
meus amigos e eu penso eu vim pra quê em
tanta gente que é que eu faço como é que
eu vou lidar com tudo isto
ou seja é algo que claramente difícil
muitas vezes não sabe como é que vai ser
uma semente que estão aqui vão
obviamente entrar no mercado de trabalho
cada trabalho tem ansiedade e associada
a isso eu vou constituir uma família e
eu saí do meu espaço
seja para tudo à nossa volta criança
cidade é um horror
mas é assim e é assim que nós vivemos de
alimento então nós temos que saber
cuidar com tudo isto
ou seja quantos nós entramos daquilo que
são as questões mais ansiosa gênicas
está uma maravilha para oc
vamos tentar ser mais reparem que quando
nós entramos aqui o que é seu genérico
vejam o que na verdade acontece temos
variáveis relacionadas com o ambiente
temos variáveis profissionais porque eu
pensamos que temos que ajudar em algo
que desperta em nós aqui uma campainha
que desperta e cria verdadeiramente
pensar em quem está aqui nós queremos um
equilíbrio homeostático por isso eu
tenho que viver em função daquilo que
são as minhas características
é muito importante quando nós estamos
verdadeiramente é trabalhar no sentido
de criar mais valia desempenho do ponto
de vista acadêmico desempenho do ponto
de vista pessoal que eu tenha presente
isto eu conseguir perceber como é que
vocês pensam que é que vocês sentem como
você se comporta
garantidamente eu consigo perceber erros
na sua essência
eu consigo trabalhar convosco agora
parei na dificuldade que o que vocês
pensam que com 60 de que o que a gente
faz no dia a dia
parece fácil não parece mas não é
verdadeiramente é isso que nós do ponto
de vista da psicoterapia temos muitas
vezes que trabalhar porque para além
daquilo que os aspectos fisiológicos
quando nós nos sentimos ansiosos os
aspectos psicológicos aspectos motores
seja a preocupação está a agitação em
capacidade de tomar decisões e soja
nós olhamos para tudo isto quando
estamos anciosos não é quando sabemos
que vamos ter uma avaliação o quanto
sabemos que temos que ter um bom
desempenho como eu aqui agora tem que
ter um ponto sempre por fazer uma
galinha como deve ser
lá dentro a minha técnica de se vocês
forem vão ganhar está mais eu vá ou não
depende daquilo que é nossa
a pressão também da constituição e é
isso que eu queria que na verdade nós
todos percebemos como é que funciona
como é que tudo isto acaba por cento que
adiar porque ainda bem que nós tínhamos
mesmo porque quem tem mesmo o movimento
com medo é uma missão adaptativa nos
ajuda a lidar com as situações o pior
plantel que é quantos estamos na verdade
com medo
completamente adaptado e se torna
verdadeiramente por capacitando aquilo
que nossa vida e para aquilo que queria
falar essa hipertensão problemas
cardiovasculares insones disfunções
sexuais com informações da cidade
por tudo isto mexe tratamento connosco e
o que nós queremos verdadeiramente é
isto é no fundo racionalizar
emocionalizar aqui opção as nossas
acções ou seja encontrar um ponto de
equilíbrio ponte que ruiu e se nos
permita verdadeiramente viver as coisas
de uma forma mais tranquilo
é eu sei que tem uma avaliação de
desempenho eu sei que tem que fazer uma
determinada aplicação eu sei que tem que
na verdade complementar uma série de
coisas mas tem que viver esta questão
agora reparem como é que nós precisamos
aqui o que é o nosso certo que isso em
36 em si aumento é que o que eu procuro
ensinar no contest psicoterapêutico e
começar o relacionamento interpessoal é
fundamental receber nos condicionarmos
com os outros é fundamental
se eu não conseguir funcionar convosco
obviamente eu vou sentindo desajustado
vamos sentir juca usado então eu tenho
como vê esse tipo de acontecimento
respiração fundamental é normal a soja é
normal que esteja mais acelerado porque
eu estou na verdade incontestável
objetivo quantas pessoas estão aqui
coisas estão a olhar pra mim é normal
que eu me sinta avaliado todos gostam a
fazer um pensamento um termo pensamento
eu tenho que na realidade saber
controlar tudo isto
dormir dormir é fundamental nossa
senhora dos meus sonhos se não dormimos
bem senão descansar não se esqueça
aquela ideia que é um mito que existe
que o kaká eu tenho uma freqüência
amanhã vou estudar esta noite toda e vou
porque depois recupera na semana
seguinte e raso ea e raso
eu tenho de dormir eu tenho que
descansar porque a partir daí eu consigo
verdadeiramente se concentrar naquilo
que eu estou a fazer é prática a prática
do exercício físico
às vezes descuramos a prática do
exercício físico é fundamental
a sociedade tem um aspecto muito
relevante do ponto de vista fisiológico
por isso eu tenho que trabalhar o
aspecto físico e determinantes
atividades da vida diária atividades de
vida diária significa o que significa
coisas que eu faça
no meu dia a dia sejam gratificantes
para mim criar situações não são
objetivos a médio longo prazo
eu quero acabar o curso quer começar a
trabalhar não está muito longe muito
longe e falta muito tempo tem que ser
atividades do nosso dia a dia
hoje quando acabar isso o que eu ganhei
com isto é isso que vai dar ao qual é o
objetivo amanhã vou ao cinema amanhã vou
correr amanhã vou fazer não sei que o
objetivo é que sejam palpáveis no nosso
dia a dia temos que ter vários caras sei
que o funil está com os amigos é
fundamental no nosso dia a dia não vale
a pena dizer assim ok eu vou na verdade
sentar na minha secretária ou abrir um
livro
estou e 10 horas em termos práticos
eu tive várias horas mas em termos de
armazenamento de informação quanto tempo
é que eu tive certo
muitas vezes não basta ter um livro
aberto é preciso ter que os estudos
também nos dizem nossa nossa capacidade
de atenção e concentração entre 45 e 50
minutos pressionou mais do que isto é
importante nós temos este presente
olha o que eu quero acima de tudo
identificar e modificar a forma
a torcida pensar é isso que aparece
muitas vezes nós temos porque fomos
educados como eu vos disse há casos em
que o autor e muitos outros falam da
transição ecológica do desenvolvimento
humano
nós somos educados como um determinado
conjunto de situações
então eu tenho que saber lidar com isso
as práticas efetivas positivas são
fundamentais são determinantes
se eu sempre vi o meu pai com uma ponte
móvel é normal que eu tenho uma ponte
maior investimento caiu sobre minha mãe
aos autos cada vez que um bicho e é
normal que desenvolver tipos de nós
aprendi 70% é pretendido por isso nós
temos que novidade
pensaram que teremos primeiramente fazer
é modificar as emissões que esses
pensamentos provocam nós acha que eu
tenho que fazer
vocês vão ver do ponto de vista daquilo
que é nosso cérebro como já vimos aqui
hoje nós temos um conjunto de situações
temos na verdade funções muito
específicas no nosso centro zonas de
preservação onde na realidade nós
controlamos
então eu tenho que verdadeiramente
perceber como é que tudo isso funcione
receber cruzamento eu consegui trabalhar
tudo isto eu só fiquei porque representa
tudo isto eu consiga alterar aquilo que
são as minhas ambições e é isso que eu
tenho que cuidar da mente fazer para
aquilo que eu dizia casa
muitas vezes eu tenho registada o
registo é fundamental
servem nas atividades da vida diária
falar sozinho falar alto é importante
é importante nós fazemos isso é
importante eu na realidade ter registro
onde eu possa verdadeiramente perceber
oq eu tive aqui uma situação de
ansiedade já tinha concluído o que eu
pensar e parece que haja uma besta o que
eu sentir para ir a ótima cidade cai o
que eu fiz sair da sala para não chatear
para a criança
ou seja essas questões todas todos nosso
incrível aumento
sentimos pensante e é isso que está em
tratamento e trabalhar
é isso que eu tenho que na verdade
pensar em utilizar formas alternativas
seja para nós temos um problema temos
uma dificuldade o que pintou o que
predispõe o que perpetua fator protetor
estratégias de coping ou seja o que eu
tô verdadeiramente a fazer para tudo
isto foi desencadeada há alguma forma eu
tenho que trabalhar isso eu tenho que
modificar isso eu tenho que pensar isto
é um crime ambiental que nós devemos ter
na nossa cabeça
quem sabe o que acontece muitas vezes
muitas vezes eu ajo e depois é que penso
para errado
o primeiro tem que pensar depois de
fugir e é isso que eu peço aqui pensamos
todos primário e depois reagimos naquilo
que é a nossa ação é para evitar que
existam situações primeiramente
complexas estruturar as crianças nuclear
possam nós temos em crenças irracionais
e continuamos a viver numa cidade onde
promove estas crianças
o pensamento da nato possui um sucesso
ou um fracasso
a personalização aqui o comentário foi
pessoal quer ter se dirige para mim é
super sonorização tudo faz de errado
catástrofes ação é melhor não tentar
pois poderia fracassar e seria horrível
para que parem tudo isso eu vou
e tudo isto é que o que eu estou a lidar
no dia a dia
então o que é que eu tenho que fazer tem
que construir estes pensamentos
estas instruções estas crianças que são
irracionais como é que nós fazemos como
é que nós trabalhamos mostrando através
do método positivo fazendo com que a
pessoa encontre a solução para os
problemas
gastar
a registar o eixo trabalhar seja muitas
vezes no consultório iguais pessoas para
fazerem exercícios nas aplicações vez
que a tecnologia hoje está o nosso a
funcionar conosco nós temos que
aproveitar isso
aquelas aplicações nós tínhamos que são
fundamentais para trabalhar aquilo que
são os exercícios de mente vamos apostar
nisso vamos trabalhar nisto é
fundamental que isso aconteça é
importante fazermos os registros para
análise do profissional e do custo
todos nós ao longo da nossa vida fazemos
isso no nosso dia a dia fazemos isso o
que o benefício o que o custo é curto
médio e longo prazo já viram já viram
que vocês tomam decisões em função disso
está aqui mas ninguém está a pensar que
está a fazer isto mas por vezes temos
que cuidar da mente fazer isto é muito
muito muito importantes que nós tínhamos
é que instrumentos de execução das
tarefas construir estratégias de
enfrentamento para nós temos capacidade
muitas vezes para poder trabalhar
este estratégias de enfrentamento seja
há um problema nós vamos resolver o
problema
não gosto de usar a prova problema no
momento isso provável dificuldades
há uma dificuldade nós vamos conseguir o
sufrágio é fundamental nós superamos os
prêmios não conseguimos superar para que
o que o modelo de aprendizagem
vamos superar com um conjunto de
técnicas que existem e que vamos aplicá
las e que vamos certamente procurar aqui
opção os comportamentos como vocês vêem
aqui por mim psi vez que menos quero
ouvir a mente terminar a dizer possíveis
de queimadas é natural faz parte do
processo terapêutico que haja situações
porque também é natural e garantindo que
havendo esse processo querida todos nós
temos outro tipo de estratégia ou outro
tipo de metas de qualidade com esse
- tal como se nós hoje tivemos uma dor
de cabeça eu sei que quais são os sinais
e sintomas hora relativamente à gestão
dos três da ansiedade eu também sei
quais são os sinais e sintomas por isso
levo é que eu esteja mais preparados
para lidar com as situações relacionadas
com os três
por isso é que os quer dizer de alimento
é que rock
nós podemos estamos certamente é
deputados para lidar com estas situações
vamos todos o iraque com estas situações
agora é verdade é que também há formas
de poder na realidade levar com essa
situação de uma forma mais tranquila e
mais treino e mais treino
lembrem-se 30% genético 70% é pretendido
por isso esses 80% que aprendi podemos
perfeitamente lidar com as situações
como ver mais uma vez questões
confinados como existe o que nós podemos
fazer é algo que faz parte
escrevam monitorizem aquilo que são os
seus compartimentos a vossa será e acima
de tudo quando não somos capazes de
lidar com as nossas situações estão três
que estamos focados nas nossas cidades
das nossas aldeias dos nossos amigos da
nossa família
procurei ajuda especializada que é
sempre aquela que nos permite
eventualmente dar a melhor resposta
possível as situações de gestão esteja
espero ter contribuído de alguma forma
por voz do estágio e acima tudo porque
hora do almoço não é uma moça tranqüilo
e sereno e sem grandes três tamanhos
obrigado pela vossa presença